(slow upbeat hip-hop music)
- [Swerte] Hip-hop is the
fastest growing culture, period.
People who don't believe that
there's hip-hop in Dubai,
or anywhere else in the world,
have been hiding in a cave.
(laughs)
- My name is P. Storm,
I'm English and Chinese.
- I'm Swerte, I'm Indonesian/Swiss.
- My name's Kaz Money,
I'm Armenian/Syrian, Italian/Eritrean.
We are The Recipe.
(intense rapping)
- [Female Narrator] In
2008, The Recipe began
as a compilation project
featuring 14 different artists
and producers in the UAE.
Today, the remaining
three members are building
a true hip-hop movement
in the Middle East.
- The hip-hop scene's
really young in Dubai,
it is very unlike any
other scene in the world
because a majority of the
population are ex-pats,
and this is a transient city,
so it is a very fast-paced culture.
It's probably the first place
where I really feel home.
Some place where I really feel accepted.
- I think what makes The
Recipe unique is we all
live in a country that
we're not really from,
so we bring different
perspectives, and it really does
play a big role in the
music that we do create.
- (rapping) ♫ I leave you
looney with these tunes,
♫ That's all folks
(spoken) Done!
- [Female Narrator] The
Recipe is breaking stereotypes
about the Middle East by showing the world
through their music that
hip-hop is truly global.
- Hey yo, it's Talib Kweli,
we with The Recipe right now,
- Yeah boy!
- Karama, you know what I'm saying?
Dubai, you know what I'm saying?
- [Female Narrator] Even
rap legends like Talib Kweli
and Mobb Deep are taking notice.
(fast rapping)
- ♫ And we breakin through,
gonna make it through
- [P. Storm] Hip-Hop is
really storytelling.
- ♫ But this is like, stuck in a place
♫ That I call my home,
but it don't play me,
♫ Cuz I can't move, right
- We really respect the craft,
so we're always inspired
to be better writers,
to be better lyricists.
♫ I'm living this life, playing this part
♫ That you really want, right?
♫ Acting this way that
you really gonna like,
♫ Got a contract, sign
for this ignorant type
- The goal was always
just to do what we love,
and thankfully by doing
that, we've been able to
achieve and experience what we've done.
- Up to this point, we've
imported everything.
Hopefully the world starts to
recognize and look at Dubai
as a viable source of music.
Somewhere that you can
look to to get music
that you actually would listen to.